when everyone and welcome you are logged
on to the first of 12 very soil and
nutrient management webinars which are
sponsored by the Northeast sustainable
research and education program ser and
they're hosted by the Cornell University
Department of Horticulture and Cornell
University Cooperative Extension my name
is Laura McDermott and today I am acting
as the moderator for this webinar
actually in place of Cathy heidenreich
who is going to be the speaker I'm just
helping her out I think we can start now
with the webinar I'm going to give you a
brief little tour in case you haven't
joined us for an Adobe Connect webinar
there are a couple of features that may
be slightly different than other
webinars that you've attended in the
lower left corner is the links you can
actually link directly to these
different websites from this webinar
page we are recording this entire
classroom so if you have questions or
the introduction that you're giving of
yourself here in the chat box those will
be recorded for future viewing for other
people and certainly you can talk to one
another if you have a product comment
that is not pertinent perhaps to the
webinar you can actually make that
comment by going over to the top right
of the chat box and kind of select
people to chat with probably most of
your chats will be pertinent though and
we do hope that you write your comments
and questions into the chat box so
they'll be recorded and that's right
down here that long bar underneath is
where you type into and then hit the
little balloon icon and that sends it
there's some files the lower right hand
corner of the digital classroom
are some files that you can download to
your own computer and you're invited to
do that at any point here in the
beginning of the class and then the
notes the agenda and other thing or in
this bar on the the pod that's on the
right hand side of the screen I think
Kathy I'm hoping that you might be able
to help me or give me an idea would you
like to do the pretest polls now
um
think is that a yes sorry
I think Kathy that you would like me to
pull these pulp the pods on is that
correct
all right i think i'm going to go ahead
and we've got some poll questions for
people to
view and you can go ahead and answer
this everyone should everyone who's
thought Don should answer
the best of your knowledge and if you
don't this is not like an essay t where
you make your best guess if you really
don't know then please just say don't
know in all of the questions that would
be really helpful
you had a question about how to submit
your answer you just go ahead and click
it and it will automatically submit
we had over 60 people sign on for this
we've got quite a large group and I
think we still have a few more people
that need to vote and I'm encouraging
you to do that because this is part of
the beginning kind of the threshold
knowledge level that will be keeping
track of as we go forward for the for
the grant
yes we are still in question 1 Lee and I
guess most people can have voted so I'm
going to close this is that all right
Kathy
all right I'm going to go ahead and
close this one and then we'll go to the
second whole pod
you
in soil PH by adding sulfur or lime
generally take effect and then just
choose and if you don't know um please
again
so I will make the pod wider
you
I think we've gotten most everybody has
voted so will close that pod now and
open the second one thank you very much
folks for bearing with us but we do need
to do these polls as part of the kind of
testing your knowledge here the best
form of nitrogen to apply to blueberries
is
and again if you don't know please admit
that and don't guess
you
I think we have about everybody there
a fair amount of question so bear with
me raspberries often display nutrient
deficiency or excess symptoms in the
field true false don't know
you
give folks
number five yep strawberries should be
fertilized in spring before Barry set
you
I think most people have answered
question five will move on to question
six
optimum soil organic matter content for
berry crops is less than three percent
greater than three percent soil organic
matter is not a critical factor in very
proud production don't know or no vote
okay very good thank you very much let's
go on to
question number 7 the best soil for
strawberry production is a well-drained
sandy loam
you
Oh
hunt oh wait a minute I think we still
gotta here I try to close that
this is question number eight soil tests
attempt to it estimate the amount of
plant available nutrients in the soil
not the total amount of nutrients in the
soil is this true or false or if you
don't know just let us know
all right I think that's everyone
you
alright this is a little cumbersome when
I'm opening these clays and soils high
in organic matter have higher nutrient
holding capacity while sands have a
lower nutrient holding capacity true or
false
you
okay I think we have everybody there
you
I think I open the wrong one so
getting a little
triet levels in berry plant tissue will
always mirror nutrient levels found in
soil true or false again thanks for
bearing with us folks um this is just
something that we need to do in order to
get a pretest level of all of your all
of your levels of information so thanks
all right I think we've got everybody
there
this is question 11 the recommended ph
for bramble plantings raspberries and
blackberries is and just choose their
again for those of you came out a little
bit later don't guess if you don't know
just put don't know
you
right thank you very much we're getting
there
it is rare for a singer single foliar
nutrient to be deficient in berry crops
often multiple deficiencies occur
simultaneously
you
you
I think we've got everybody's out there
it's time to collect berry leaves for
fully or analysis is
you
you
it I think we have everybody
and that was 13 right so an hour on 14
soil tests provide accurate results for
all essential mineral nutrients while
foliar analysis does not true or false
all right thank you folks
you
I think we're on question 15 okay I hope
you're keeping track and makes I'm
losing track of which question we're on
visual diagnosis of berry crop nutrient
problems is accurate and precise true or
false
you
right very good and that was 15 you're
getting very close folks recommended pH
levels for strawberry is 4.22 4.5 5.5 to
6.0 60 to 65 and 65 to 70 or don't know
when it's a perfectly legitimate answer
you
you
I think we have everyone there will go
on to question 17
since 17 a combination of soil testing
tissue analysis and observation of crop
responses the best approach to assessing
berry crop nutrient status true false or
don't know
okay excellent going to move to question
18
soil health may be improved by frequent
cultivation to improve soil drainage
true or false or don't know
I thank you all for voting we have two
more pods left two more pull pods
question 19 characteristics of a healthy
soil include good soil tilth sufficient
depth and excessive supply of nutrients
a small population of microorganisms or
don't know and you can check all that
apply all that are correct
will be trickier for me to see if
everyone has voted because we've got
multiple answers but when they stopped
ticking up that's when we'll close this
and we'll go to the last poll
alright thank you and for the last
pretest question soil and leaf samples
for testing should be collected in a
v-shaped sampling pattern across the
entire planting
say true false or don't know
I think everyone is voted I thank you
for hanging in there with us for that
pre test group of questions i do want to
point out one way that you can you can
always try to get our attention through
the chat box or you can on the top bar
there's a little icon with a hand up you
can raise your hand and we'll try to
make sure that we address whatever your
question is I think I'm going to move us
now into the next segment on which is a
presentation segment and introduce Kathy
heidenreich to you if I can remember how
to do that sorry
um and I do want to introduce Cathy
heidenreich many of you know Kathy she
is the Cornell University a very
extension support specialist she was my
partner in crime when we were doing a
new york farm viability berry project
and she's a really great person very
dedicated to bury education and she is
standing in for dr. Marvin Pritts who is
currently flying back from the ashs
meetings in hawaii and kathy will
probably be the moderator for many of
the webinars upcoming but she's going to
take over the introductory part and
Kathy MA yes oh I'm I'm really happy
technology is great when it works but
all during the quiz my audio was not
working so I'm sorry I couldn't help out
that's ok and I think everybody
hopefully everybody will be able to hear
you I can hear you're just perfectly
great well thank you everyone for coming
today I'm very excited about this
project this actually was one of the
first successful grant proposals that
I've written and I'm really really happy
with the response we have 66 people
registered already if you have other
colleagues who would be interested in
participating it's not too late for them
they're more than welcome to attend if
you missed the pretest or if you haven't
filled out the registration form when we
get to the end you'll be able to
download those in the last screen and
please feel free to email those to me so
today I just want to give you an
overview of the project and we're going
to start I think with the title soil
management and very crops as a model for
management education so our hope was
while providing information on Barry
crops in terms of soil nutrient
management that the information that you
learn and the resources that will become
available to you will also be applicable
a call across a wide variety of crops
and so we're very excited about this and
very happy that you've joined us so
we're just going to take a quick look at
the project itself there were several
issues that we identified in the course
of the work that I've done for dr.
Marvin Prince at Cornell and one of them
is that commercial berry growers in the
Northeast traditionally have applied
fertilizer based on crop age so you know
if the crops or less than a year old no
application in that particular year if
their one-year-old or two years old a
certain poundage of fertilizer is
applied and then as they increase in age
that number probably goes up so this
practice is still very popular today
some ten years or more after commercial
berry crop guidelines have shifted to an
analysis based fertilization program and
the testing has become very good and
widely available are very reasonable
costs and then the other issue is that
because Barry crops are by nature a
perennial crop system adoption of soil
health improving practices has also been
slow so on the educator multiplier end
of it on your end of it we discovered
that although your frequently called on
to cover multiple commodities or
information areas they often fall
outside of your field of expertise and
so it's a struggle to assist commercial
berry growers with their soil nutrient
problems and there is no single
comprehensive resource for this topic
that's available either for you as
educators or for growers so this is an
issue that doctor puts and I discussed
quite frequently and decided we wanted
to try to address and we want to thank
northeast sarah for funding this project
so it's a two-year project and we're
hoping to provide in-depth very crop
circle nutrient management training and
resources for you
and in turn you can use these to assist
commercial growers so the first year of
the plan we're going to try to help you
build some expertise and the webinars
series is the first phase of that plan
and we're also going to have some case
study learning modules on the subject
for you in the meantime we're also
developing resources to be used by you
and grower training and so i'll be
sending out to you at some point in the
next week or two the link to abate a
website that we would like you to look
at and use and review and we would like
your input on how we can make that the
best resource possible for the job at
hand and then in year two of the project
we're hoping that some of you will
develop and implement grower training
and we're willing to assist you with
that and that you'll participate some
growers to do soil nutrient testing and
within the Northeast region we do have
funds available through the grant for 50
growers to receive complimentary soil
nutrient testing if you're outside the
Northeast region there may be some other
options will I'm willing to discuss that
with you so we're hoping that two to
three growers / training event will be
participating in testing and then
implementing at least on a portion of
their planting an analysis based
fertilization program and then we're
asking that you might carry out
one-on-one consultations with
participating growers to discuss results
and we'd like to capture those results
and their feedback on it to use to help
convince other growers hopefully to do
the same so I just wanted to share a
little bit with you about the team
members and collaborators the man in the
purple shirt on the right is dr. Marvin
Fritz he's the professor and chair of
the horticulture department at Cornell
University and he sends his apologies he
forgot to include the time change and he
thought he would be back in time to do
this presentation and unfortunately he's
still in the air somewhere but his
expertise is buried crop production and
the soil nutrient management and I'm
going to be the project coordinator for
the project and I'm also in the
Department of Horticulture at Cornell
and my expertise is in berry crop
production and pest management this is a
multidisciplinary project and we're very
happy that dr. Harold vanasse has agreed
to collaborate with us he's professor
and chair of the Department of crop and
soil Sciences at Cornell his expertise
is soham order management and this is a
picture of Harold down under in
Australia and Bob Jindal Beck is also a
collaborator from the same department he
works very closely with Harold in the
soil health testing project that's
happening at Cornell University and his
expertise is so health testing and soil
management we have four other team
members mr. Jeff Miller is one of our
team members he's from an Ida County
Cooperative Extension he's the
agriculture issues leaders their issue
leader there and his expertise is in
agronomy mr. dan welch is also a member
of our team he's a extension resource
educator with Cayuga County Cooperative
Extension and his field of expertise is
farm business management he's going to
be tracking the economic of nutrient
management for us so we'll have a
comparison between a calendar based crop
age fertilization plan and plans based
on test analysis results Mario Miranda
zazo is another of our team members he's
the tree fruit and berry fruit extension
specialist with the lake ontario fruit
team and his expertise is cultural
practices anavar team at Laura McDermott
our host she's a regional specialist
with a capital district vegetable and
fruit program with Cornell Cooperative
Extension another expertise is blank so
apologize for that Laura her expertise
is in best vegetable and berries small
fruits she also has true fruit
experience so let's take a look at you
you were very kind to fill out the
demographics survey those of you who
have not you'll be able to download it
at the end please send it back to me by
email as I said before there are 66 of
you and your spread across the country
and into Canada as you can see we have
people from Illinois Massachusetts Maine
Michigan New Hampshire New York Ohio
Pennsylvania Vermont wisconsin wyoming
west virginia and connecticut
48 of you are associated with a college
or university 12 are associated with a
government agency for t involved in
extension ADA are associated with usda
nrcs three of you work with organic
production organic producers and seven
are associated with other enterprises
and by the way I didn't include the
demographics in terms of age but I have
to say that we all fall in that mid
career category so we need to be
recruiting some younger people to join
us in terms of occupation they were many
edge extension and AG educators
professors instructors soil
conservationists agronomists and
planners consultants horticultural
research I p.m. and extension
specialists scientists district managers
and conservationists technical advisors
program coordinators water stewardship
and soil conservation technicians
outreach coordinators program leaders
environmental biologists and engineers
and and apart from the professional
expertise fields that I listed on the
demographic survey we have people who
are in environmental compliance consumer
horticulture conservation technology
Plant Pathology sustainable agriculture
agronomy land protection pesticide
education soil management and best
management practices so how are we going
to measure the success of the project
we've already taken one step toward that
in the pretest that you all participated
in and I thank you for that and just to
warn you there will be another test at
the end to measure the expertise that's
been gained and then throughout the
project and in subsequent years we're
going to monitor the adoption and
success of analysis based berry crop
nutrient soil management by the
commercial growers who participate in
the project
so our final goal then is to have 50
educators participate in the training to
expand their expertise and of those that
15 will develop and deliver some sort of
an outreach program on the same to 150
berry growers who manage approximately
750 acres of berry crops and then we're
hoping that 50 of those growers will
participate in preliminary soil nutrient
and/or soil health testing and then
receive one-on-one assistance with
interpretation of the results and then
implement that on farm okay are there
any questions
you
you
you
if there are no more questions I think
we can move into the final just the kind
of the exit and make sure please to
notice that there are the links that you
might be interested in checking out
there are all these intro files and
Kathy apparently my little cursor was of
showing so people could actually see
what I was voting on so you'll see where
my challenges lie in my responses and
did you were there post poll questions
for this segment or is that at the very
end no Laura that's going to be at the
end excellent good I do want to make
sure that everybody knows that next week
a week from today at the same time our
our topic will be introduction to soil
management and we'll be talking about
soil types accessing soil surveys
physical properties of soil etc that
webinar will be led by dr. Harrell
vaness and I think that that's that's
that's it for today Kathy I probably
have forgotten something so please jump
in if I have forgotten anything I just
wanted to point out that all of these
webinars are being recorded and you'll
be able to view them if you miss one or
review them by going to the website so
if you look in the links box on the
bottom left of your screen you'll see
soil a nutrient management webinar
archive if you click on that and then
the Browse to button it will take you to
that page I'll try to have these posted
by Monday or Tuesday of the week
following the webinar please don't share
that link with anyone else it's a beta
website right now and once all of the
webinars are completed and recorded
everyone will have public access to
those so hopefully now that everyone
knows the targets and understands what
we are hoping maybe people will start
formulating in your head
you can use this information to do
outreach if that's part of your job
description please plan on having
probably twice as long or even an hour
and 15 minutes webinar next week we
expect that that's how long the
presentations will be and thank you very
much for joining us it is sure to be a
great series of informational webinars
every weekend
see there are a few questions Hillary
asked about a list of subjects that will
be covered if you download the webinar
schedule in the file box on the right
you'll be able to get all of the topics
dates are also there please feel free to
invite any of your colleagues who you
think might be interested in the program
to join us and if you haven't completed
the demographics questionnaire please do
that
you
you
see you next week
you